the ruined hideout of isolator abu
ibrahimal quraishi in northwest syria
pinned down by the u.s special forces
during a counter-terrorism raid on
thursday president joe biden said
al-qurayshi blew himself up to avoid
capture
12 other people including six children
were also killed
the iraqi national was accused of
orchestrating isil attacks in syria and
iraq
his neighbors in the town of atma are
shocked that they live next to a
notorious outlaw
around 1am we went out and saw five
helicopters flying low we didn't know
who the target was there was a one-hour
gunfight and special forces landed on
the building they spent two hours there
we gathered with the children in one
house the children couldn't bear it they
were so afraid
and his predecessor abu bakr al-baghdadi
both chose to hide among families of
internally displaced syrians
we were asleep when we heard the
explosions then they called on everyone
men women children to evacuate the
building saying they would destroy it
they tied us up and asked us a lot of
questions i told them i don't know
anyone from next door
a croatia's landlord says he had no idea
about his tenant now he's trying to
repair the damage to his property
here this person has been here for a
year he said he was an idp i rented in
the house like regular people how could
i know or verify his real identity we
don't acknowledge or tolerate terrorism
we are harmed because of this man and
this raid
isil's remaining leaders haven't
commented on the raid which killed their
comrade after the killing of two isil
leaders by the united states over the
last three years many across the border
fear the group will see that as a
challenge and that could provoke more
fear and hostility in the region and
returns of people being forced towards
the border with turkey cinnamon solo al
jazeera hotel vegas crossing